Um, okay, let's go to our caller from the
five, four zero area code. Who's calling today
from five four zero.
Hi, David. Um, I'm William.
Hey William. What's going on?
The reason I'm calling, the reason I'm calling
today is been a subscriber listening group
your short a couple of years now and for the
most part a very much enjoy your programming.
Um, but I had a, I and others had tried to
bring to your attention, um, this new, uh,
called the new independence for the men, the
staff.
Okay. You're breaking up. Thank you. Said
that the group is called the new independent
fundamentalist. What?
Yeah. Yeah.
Baptists. Okay.
Okay. The [inaudible]. Um, and then their
main point of the, matter of fact, they had
a rally on the weekend of the, uh, pulse nightclub
shooting down in Orlando. And, um, and basically
what they're trying to do is they're trying
to rile up their people to try to get the
government to, um, not only make homosexual
homosexuality, illegal execute homosexual
homosexuals.
Yeah. There have been groups with that idea
around for a while. Um, you know, the, it's
not going anywhere. I mean, there's not really
a risk that that's going to happen in the
u s and they're going to have to ban gay marriage
before they go to killing the gays. So I just
don't know that I've not heard of this group.
I'll look into them, but it doesn't sound
like they have much influence.
Well, the thing is that since 2006, they have
grown to having over 40 churches across the
country and they continue to, to grow. And
just recently in Tennessee, um, there was
a pastor who was also a sheriff or deputy
sheriff in that town who was a member of the
NFB who was calling for the, for the execution.
And you just said that you would look into
it. And I guess that's why I called because
I know I in several other, um, people had
had, uh, I had gone on your subreddit and
I had also sent you an in regards to this
and I hadn't heard anything.
Okay. I appreciate that. I mean, just understand
that, you know, we get every day we get about
3000 contacts from the audience across our,
all of our different platforms. So I can't
re react or respond to everything individually
or cover everything, but I'll check into this
group you're talking about
and I would appreciate that very much.
All right, very good. Thank you so much for
the call. Great to hear from you. Let's go
to break. Sorry. As always
to everybody. I didn't get to, but I am under
advice from the audience spending a little
more time with each color. Um, we'll see if
people like that and we will take calls again
next week.